-Many of
President Trump's nominees
to top government positions
have been questionable,
but perhaps none more so than
his choice to head
the Department of Energy,
Rick Perry,
who once wanted to abolish the
very agency he's now leading.
So we decided to take a break
from the breaking news of
the day and see how he's doing.
It's time for "The Check In."
♪♪
[ Bell dings ]
Now most people were probably
surprised that Donald Trump
nominated former
Governor of Texas, Rick Perry,
to lead
the Department of Energy,
as he was once Trump's rival
in trying to get
the Republican nomination
for President for 2016.
In fact, Perry even called
Trump's candidacy
a cancer on conservativism.
And Trump countered with some
of his trademark insult comedy.
-I see Rick Perry the other day,
and he's so --
You know, he's doing very poorly
in the polls.
He put glasses on so people
will think he is smart.
[ Laughter ]
And it just doesn't work!
You know, people can see
through the glasses.
But he's got the glasses,
the whole deal.
"Oh-oh, oh, Trump, huh."
-The list of reasons to dislike
Trump is long, I know,
but I'm gonna add the laziness
of his impressions.
"Oh, oh-ho-ho-uh..."
[ Laughter ]
That could be anybody.
[ Imitating Trump ] Meanwhile,
you got Marco Rubio. Oh...uh...
[ Laughter ]
Then Ted Cruz is like oh...uh...
[ Normal voice ] Now the great
irony in Perry's nomination
perhaps lost only on Trump
is that the Department of Energy
is one of the agencies Perry
said he wanted to abolish
back in 2011 when
he was running for President.
That is, before he forgot it was
the agency he wanted
to get rid of.
-It's three agencies of
government when I get there that
are gone -- commerce, education
and the, uh...
what's the third one there?
Let's see.
-You can't name the third one?
-The third agency of government
I would do away with,
education, uh, the, uh...
[ Laughter ]
-Commerce.
-I...commerce, and let's see.
-Oh, my.
-I can't.
The third one, I can't. Sorry.
[ Laughter ]
Oops.
-Now, that should have
been it.
[ Laughter ]
That should have been the last
time anyone saw Rick Perry.
Once you Bill Buckner
a debate like that,
you should be the answer
to a trivia question, at best.
The only thing worse would be if
you straight up didn't know
the voting age
or when election day was.
-Those of you that are -- will
be 21 by November the 12th,
I ask for your support
and your vote.
-[ Groans ]
[ Laughter ]
No, it's 18 to vote, and
Election Day was November 6th.
So we didn't know the agency
you wanted to abolish
or when election day was
or what the voting age is,
but surely -- surely Rick Perry
knows where he is
at any given time.
-There are many other states
that embrace those conservative,
uh, values -- the approach that
we've taken over the years.
I'm in one today in Florida.
You look at South Carolina.
You look at Florida.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay. But that, guys...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I know it seems like we're
piling on, but that has to be
the most embarrassing clip
of Rick Perry. What's that?
There are more? How many more?
Thousands more.
All right, well,
let's just go with one more
for the sake of time.
-Rick Perry!
♪♪
-♪ Ice, ice baby ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's the guy currently in
charge of our nuclear arsenal.
No, not Vanilla Ice.
Vanilla Ice would be a step up.
[ Laughter ]
Now you would think that
Rick Perry would take the time
to familiarize himself
with the kind of work
the Department of Energy, whose
budget exceeds $30 billion does.
But according to
the "New York Times,"
when then-President-elect Trump
offered Perry the job...
Imagine finding out after you
accepted a job that
the job description included
managing nuclear weapons.
I got pissed when I found out
mine included animal segments.
[ Laughter ]
So Perry accepted a role he was
confused about, and then somehow
made it through
the confirmation process.
Although we shouldn't be
surprised, as the Senate also
confirmed Betsy DeVos
for Secretary of Education,
already resigned Tom Price
for Secretary
of Health and Human Services,
and a haunted doll
as Secretary of Commerce.
But we would hope that once he
officially had the job,
Perry would try to learn more
from someone like
his predecessor,
Dr. Ernest Moniz,
a nuclear physicist.
Interesting fact -- Moniz became
a nuclear physicist
when his high school
guidance counselor
took a look at him
and said it's either that
or Ben Franklin impersonator.
[ Laughter ]
But according to a source cited
in a "Vanity Fair" report
from July, Perry barely spent
any time with Moniz.
According to the reporter's
sources, he writes that Perry...
But in Perry's defense,
he doesn't doesn't really need
to be an expert
in nuclear energy when his boss
already has such a good handle
on it.
-You know what uranium is,
right? Think of nuclear weapons
and other things, like lots
of things are done with uranium,
including some bad things.
-Perry saw that and thought,
"Oh, he's already up
to speed. We're good."
But reports started surfacing
back in the summer
that Perry had
fallen out of favor with Trump
and that Trump was actually
looking to replace him,
which is also when
this happened.
-Russia's messing
with U.S. politicians again,
but this time,
it's Russian pranksters,
and they tricked Secretary
of Energy, Rick Perry,
into believing he was having
a conversation
with the Ukrainian
Prime Minister.
-That's right.
Russian pranksters pretending
to be the Prime Minster
of Ukraine...
...with Perry.
A 20-minute prank call.
Even the Jerky Boys would say,
"hey, man, this is fun,
but we have places to be."
[ Laughter ]
And we don't know for sure how
Perry recovered from that
and won Trump back over, but it
may have something to do
with Perry's new controversial
energy proposal
which would basically force
consumers to subsidize old,
failing coal and nuclear
power plants
that would otherwise likely
be obsolete.
According to reports
and analysis, this plan would...
So why provide this preferential
treatment to aging industries
at the potential expense
of millions of consumers?
Well, according to reports,
Perry's plan...
Ah, yes, Bob Murray,
the litigious coal tycoon,
who apparently needs this
administration's help so much,
reports say that his company,
Murray Energy...
Ugh. Imagine if
your whole livelihood
came down to Rick Perry.
It's like when the Vietnam War
came down to Forrest Gump.
[ Laughter ]
But it's not just Perry.
And of course, as with other
government agencies,
Trump has made other
questionable hires
at the Department of Energy,
like bringing in
Eric Trump's brother-in-law,
Kyle Yunaska, for example.
Yunaska, who's the brother of
Eric Trump's wife, Lara Trump,
was recently
promoted to the position
of Chief of Staff for
the department's office
of Energy Policy
and Systems Analysis.
Sounds like a pretty important
job for someone who must have
an impressive background
in energy policy.
Well, according to "Newsweek,"
Yunaska's...
Okay, fine, but is there
anything else on his résumé
that shows he's qualified?
Let's see. Oh! There.
Reports say...
And there's a picture.
That's him on the end.
-Oh!
-Now for someone who works for
the Department of Energy,
it's not exactly reassuring that
he doesn't even have the energy
to get off the ground.
[ Laughter ]
So we have inexperienced leaders
seemingly beholden,
special interests,
and family members
getting top jobs
at the Department of Energy,
So at this point, if something
goes wrong, the only explanation
I guess we should expect is, uh,
what's the elegant phrase
I'm looking for?
-Oops.
-That's what I thought.
This has been "The Check In."
♪♪
[ Bell dings ]